ushiro kubushime
um
so in this technique Mike's grabbing my
hand so if I was going to grab my weapon
he's controlling it so it'd be very
difficult for me to get my weapon he's
coming from behind me and he's choking
me now anytime I'm being choked the most
important thing is to get a hand in and
my chin down right so it doesn't matter
if my hand goes in underneath or over
the top whatever's easier to get it in
you need your hand in your hand is
keeping you from getting choked so this
is creating space for you and at the
same time you're trying to eat your chin
down once my Chin's down it's very
difficult to choke not impossible but
hard for jokes so I'm gonna get my hand
in chin down now this hand should be in
front of my Center again if we're in a
weapon situation I could probably get a
weapon from here but we're gonna move on
with the technique from this point I'm
going to express poke you in my hand
getting Mike's elbow up and my elbow
underneath his I'm going to slide to the
inside here and come to this position
now important important thing to notice
here is if I choose the wrong direction
if I turn towards Mike's hand instead of
his elbow Mike's gonna choke me right so
even if I can really far let me get a
little brother if I get really far like
this you see his truck she's getting
Tighter and Tighter however if I go the
other direction this way my shoulder
gets in between me and Mike and I can
stop him from choking me so you always
want to roll towards his elbow so my
hands in front of my Center I roll
towards the elbow now from here you can
see the sun feels ready to go I reach up
and control it put control into mic push
his elbow down come out bring him down
from here drop the inside knee free hand
comes to the Sancho dropping this knee
apply sound too one more time to speed
right and now